Speaker 1: Rudy Giuliani, who was at one point
known as mayor, 911, who presided over the
city of New York as its mayor during and in
the immediate aftermath of the 911 attacks,
appeared on Real America's Voice with Dr.
Jena.
Now, we'll get to this Dr. Jena thing in a
second.
Why?
Why is she Dr. Jena and why what kind of a
doctor if she pay really close attention to
this clip?
Rudy Giuliani does not reject 911 conspiracies.
In this interview when the host floats.
Listen, I'm not that conspiratorial, but I'm
starting to wonder about some of these conspiracy
theories about 911, myself and Rudy, rather
than rejecting out of hand those conspiracy
theories which relate to an event that happened
in New York while he was governor I'm sorry,
mayor of New York City.
He sort of says, yeah, there's lots of stuff
that I didn't believe which turned out to
be true.
Check this out and pay really close attention
to the language being used here.
Speaker 6: And Mayor, I guess I just I have
to ask you this, because it struck me yesterday
as I as I looked through the post, you know,
you always see all the posts on social media
on September 11th, and rightly so.
We should absolutely remember and never forget.
But I noticed but see the strong uptick and
the number of folks asking about things that
have traditionally been painted, conspiracy
theories regarding September 11th.
And I noticed a lot of people saying things
like this is disrespectful to those who've
died and those who suffered.
To ask any questions about it.
But I also know, Mayor.
Not only did you live through 911, you've
been a target of the federal government.
You've been one of those people who has been
persecuted.
One of the 50 or more we know at this point,
persecuted basically for doing your job and
being friends with the president.
Speaker 1: So I just so understand the connection
that's being drawn here.
Okay.
Dr. Gina says, listen, I'm not big on these
911 conspiracy theories, but.
I'm now starting to be a little more sympathetic
to the 9/11 conspiracy theory people, because
similarly, there are people who said things
about you, Mr. Mayor, that turned out to be
untrue as well.
And so if those those things were wrong, maybe
the conspiracy theories about 911 are right.
That's what Dr. Gina is saying now, by the
way.
Let's talk and we're going to continue with
the clip.
Dr. Gina, this is Gina Loudon.
She's known as Dr. Gina.
She's just a right wing media personality.
Now, you might remember when it was Dr. Jill
Biden, all of these right wingers were saying
that's not a medical doctor.
Why are they calling her Dr. Jill Biden?
That's absolutely crazy.
She's a doctor of education.
Dr. Gina has a Ph.D. in human and organization
systems from Fielding Graduate University,
which is an online school.
Now there's nothing wrong with online school
or any of it, but that it is completely irrelevant
to her role as the host of the Dr. Gina Show.
Just so many people might not even know this.
Rachel MADDOW was a Rhodes Scholar and has
a doctorate of philosophy in politics from
the University of Oxford.
Okay, it would still be a bit much to say.
Dr. Rachel MADDOW.
The Dr. Rachel MADDOW Show.
Although I would argue that her dphil in politics
from Oxford is more relevant and more impressive
than what makes Gina Louden a doctor.
But where were they when it was Dr. Jill Biden's
degree?
Shouldn't be mentioned, but yet now it's the
Dr. Gina show.
It's absurd.
And you'll actually hear Rudy refer to her
as doctor, which is just like the cherry on
top.
Speaker 6: I guess I kind of was thinking
yesterday, I, I don't believe the things that
I've read about that, but I, I don't fault
people any more for asking questions that
may sound outlandish when our government is
a proven enemy of some people.
Mary, I wanted to give you a chance to speak
to this.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, you know, Doctor, that's
really hard.
Speaker 1: Why does it feel absurd for him
or to to refer to her as doctor in this context?
Speaker 2: I find myself now saying things
and realizing they're true, that if I had
said them five years ago, I would have thought
I was crazy.
Right.
And I would have.
Speaker 1: Said, well, we think you're crazy
now for saying, all.
Speaker 2: Right, let's take Russian collusion,
that a political party would spend a couple
million dollars to make up a charge to frame
a candidate for president.
Then to try to frame a president and remove
him on a charge that was purchased and is
a complete lie.
Carry it on for four or five years and have
the support of the American press.
I would say that's crazy.
That can't happen.
That can't possibly happen.
The press will be outraged.
She'll go nuts.
And once they found out that it was a complete
fraud, they just go on to the next front.
The whole thing with the Ukraine, which turned
out to be another fraud.
And then they go on to suppress the the hard
drive, which can change.
Speaker 1: So basically what Rudy is saying
is, instead of Dr. Gina, let me be very clear.
Dr.. Dr.. Gina, did I mention.
Dr.. I was mayor of 911 when that happened.
And what took place on that day is that more
than a dozen men, mostly Saudis, attacked
us and they flew two planes and then another
one crashed in Pennsylvania.
You know, he doesn't do that.
He instead says, hey, listen, I know what
you're saying about maybe these conspiracy
theories are right.
There was the Russia thing and then there
was the Ukraine thing, as he says it, and
on and on and on.
He is not rejecting the idea that the 911
conspiracy theories may be true.
He was mayor of New York during 911.
And he now and again, I don't actually think
Rudy believes any of the conspiracy theories.
I think Rudy knows exactly what happened on
911 the way the way we've all gotten to the
bottom of it, as Donald Trump says, we have
not.
But he has been so sucked in by this, just
a vile right wing movement, non thinking movement,
that this is the answer that he has to give.
It's a sad state of affairs